Автомобіль як знаряддя вбивства: терористи дедалі частіше використовують авто замість зброї.
Наїзд на людей у Барселоні 17 серпня - найактуальніший приклад. За останній рік
жертвами подібних терактів стали люди у цілій низці європейських міст.
У Лондоні сталося кілька авто-нападів. Третього червня 2017-го троє чоловіків спрямували
мікроавтобус у пішоходів на Лондонському мості, перш ніж кинутися з ножами
на людей у барах і ресторанах поблизу ринку Боро. Семеро людей загинули.
До цього 22 березня британець, який прийняв іслам, наїхав на пішоходів на Вестмінстерському
мості, поранив полісмена й убив чотирьох людей.
Стокгольм, сьоме квітня. Терорист на вантажівці вбив п'ятьох людей, розігнавши авто пішохідною
вулицею шведської столиці та в'їхавши у торговий центр. Відповідальність на себе взяли терористи "Ісламської держави".
Берлін, 19 грудня 2016-го. Різдвяний ринок став мішенню ісламістського нападу. Прибічник ІД
Аніс Амрі викрав фуру і спрямував її у натовп, убивши 12 людей. Кілька днів по тому його застрелила поліція в Мілані.
Ніцца, 14 липня 2016. Психічно хворий чоловік, якого "Ісламська держава" оголосила одним зі своїх терористів,
в'їхав на вантажівці у натовп людей під час святкування Дня взяття Бастилії. Загинули 86 людей, понад 200 зазнали поранень.
Захиститись від подібних атак, схоже, неможливо. Адже щоб автомобіль перетворився на зброю, достатньо лише натиснути на газ.